تغطيه تعرض فريق فرانكات الى الضرب
والاعتداء اللفظي من قبل مجموعه من الشباب
خلال التغطيه على الهواء مباشره
للحديث معنا السميله ليلى عوده ليلى علتي
الى منزلك الحمد لله على السلامه ما الذي
حدث خلال هذه المضايقات التي هذه الشتائم
اللغه العبريه ما الذي حدث تحديدا ومن
الذي قيل لك من هؤلاء الشباب
مساء الخير شكرا عزيزه بالفعل كنا نقوم
بعملنا كاي صحفي تواجد في المكان سواء من
الصحفيين الذين تواجدوا للقنوات العربيه
او حتى الفرنسيه الانجليزيه العبريه
التركيه كل هذه القنوات كانت متواجده ولكن
بطبيعه الحال كانت هناك نشرتها الاولى همم
لم نتعرض لاي شيء همم تجولنا في المكان
تحدث باللغه العربيه
وكنت ااه اتحدث بالشرح المفصل عن ما جرى
بين هؤلاء المتشددين ولكن بطبيعه الحال في
النشره الثانيه همم
على الهواء مباشره
بعد متدينين بالتجمهر همم حولي واا لم
الاحظ كل شيء ولكن ده طبيعه الحال ما
لمسته من من شاهدته بجانبه هو بدا هؤلاء
بالتجمع باستخدام الفاظ بديئه اشاره
باصابعها ما همم لا لا لا ترقى للمستوى
الاخلاقي وطبيعه الحال كانوا يقولون لو لو
وجود للارهابيين لا نريد وجود العرب هنا
هي تتحدث العربيه اصبحوا ينادون بعضهم
البعض لانني اتحدث العربيه هذه تتحدث
العربيه اكتشفوا انني اتحدث العربيه تتحدث
العربيه اذا هي فلسطينيه همم
يفهموا ان سمعتهم العرب
هنا غادر همم اذهبي من هنا لا تبكي هنا
هنا حتى هذه القضيه تفهم على انها تهديد
هذا بعد ان همم
الترجمه العبريه التي حصلنا عليها هم
قالوا الموت للعرب خلال هذه همم الالفاظ
نعم
فعلا الموت للعرب الموت للارهابيين حتى
بعد خروجنا في مغادرتنا البث التجمع
رولينا باعداد اكبر الوضع كان جديه لم يكن
هناك يعني ايضا هل تدخلت لحمايتكم
هذه النقطه الرئيسيه
محاوله الاعتداء علينا المصور تم الاعتداء
عليها تم كسر
الحامل التي تحمل الكاميرا كانت هناك
الفاظ بديئه جدا لا استطيع حتى ذكرها على
الهواء
يعرفون اللغه العبريه وحصلنا على الترجمه
هو شكل احد افراد الشرطه ندحته قلت له
باننا في خطر يعني نطلب الحمايه على
اعتبار ان هناك ان هذا هؤلاء يزعجوننا
نريد ان نكمل عملنا لدي شغل لدي عمل لدي
بث مباشر ايه ما اكتفى به قال لي لا تقفي
هنا غادر المكان على الفور على الفوق كل
هذا كل ما تستطيع ان تقوله لي انا هنا
اريد ان اعمل واريد ان استكمل عملي قال لي
اقول لك من هنا وغادر هذا المكان لا
تواصلي الوقوف في هذا المكان قلت له هل
ترى كم كيف يحاولون الهجوم علينا الاعتداء
علينا عاد الكرى قال غادر هذا المكان حين
ادركت انه همم بامكان الاستمرار والمخاطره
بحياتي وحياتي المصور لان الوضع تازم احد
الصحفيين الاسرائيلين حول مساعدتنا ولكنني
قلت لها هل تدرك الفرق ما بيني وبينك انا
صحفيه اتواجد هنا لاعمل وكان كذلك صحفي
تتواجد هنا لتعمل الفرق ما بيني وبينك
انني اتحدث عربيه وانت تتحدث العبريه
لكنني صحفيه وانت صحفي نغطي ذات الحدث قال
لي معك حق وهذا صحيح لا نستطيع ان عمل شيء
ان اردت مساعده انا موجود ولكن بطبيعه
الحال لكن الاحد من مساعدتنا لان الوضع
اصبح خطير حااصرون من كل الجهات وكان
الوضع فعلا جدا جديا وليس اي مجال هناك
للمغامره اكثر من ذلك لذلك غدا شكرا جزيلا
لك ليلى عوده وحمد لله على السلامه مجددا